I want to begin by,
uh, taking up some, uh,
general questions,
uh,
concerning the Quixote matters,
such as the difference
between romance and novel.
Because I know from the last
lecture that you must, uh,
be confused and it's good to know it
other matters which are what,
what is it she Valerie romance because
you hear a lot about it and I'm sure and
that very few people know,
why don't you vote or romance was,
uh, and uh, who were the,
uh,
Spanish precursors of Cervantes because I,
I want to as much as possible,
although in English to give you a said
Vantis in his own sauce as it were,
that is within the Spanish tradition
as well as the European but also with,
but within the Spanish tradition,
uh,
I do that to counter
versions of the Quixote, uh,
taught here at Yale in the
English department and uh, uh,
and directed studies and
so forth valuable courses,
but in which surrounds this is seen only
in the context of Western literature.
So this is why I want to give,
you sort of answered this as much
as possible in his own salsa.
I said were in its own sauce.
Now I will begin by, uh, continuing, uh,
on the issue of what
one, why the Quixote, Eh,
has continued to be, uh, to be read.
Why it has had such common currency.
I just learned yesterday that
the detainees in one animal,
uh, Cuba, uh, ask for the
Quixote, first of all,
uh, of all the books or
they want to read. Now,
I have offered the most common
of answers about Hawaii.
The Quixote is so current,
the least a specialized,
the one that I assume a general readers
would understand about wanting to be all
there and so forth that I
spoke about in the last class.
But Doki Haka is notoriously about
literature covering the entire range of
about,
first and foremost is about the effect
that literature has on its readers.
Don't Quixote goes mad because
he reads too much literature.
Literature fiction allows
us to rehearse in private.
Our most secret desires are effecting
our lives as if these desires come true.
Uh, it's like dreams,
dreams of the same effect.
This is its allure, the allure of
literature. And also it's danger.
We can live lives other than ours,
full of adventures on Trammell by
society's constraints and by our own
limitations.
Does doing that purchase of those desires,
uh,
or does it induce more desires,
and induce the desire to close the
gap between desire and reality.
But the hotter is also in addition
about the creation of literature,
the relationship each text has with this,
with previous texts as well as
about questions of Literary John,
Huh.
The Quixote appears at the end of
the renaissance when improvements,
uh,
of the printing press that created
a mass readership sorta speak mass
readership, nothing compared
to what we have today. Uh,
a mass readership for the first time in
history and when the discovery analysis
and imitation of classical TVCs,
uh,
on poetics had brought to
the four questions about
content and form as well as
of ethics,
public and private.
As you know, the renaissance,
uh, involved, uh,
or renaissance humanists were
interested in the classics,
in reading the classics
in the original, in, um,
in editing the classics
to make them available.
What is secular literature good for?
What is good literature?
How do new ideas about reading and
writing affect the interpretation of
scripture
is secular literature in the vernacular,
a danger to faith,
religious faith,
leaky hot,
the is full of writers and readers.
You will meet them as you read
the book of books, Stories, poems,
and of people,
young and old affected by literature.
You would meet some very early Marcel
[inaudible] customer [inaudible].
I'm sorry.
Now in this vein about Don Quixote
and the issue of literature is the
originality of the donkey hotel story.
The fact that it does not belong
to any known tradition or cycle,
be it from the pastoral or
Chavarria or chivalry cycles.
Uh, not to mention, uh,
popular narratives or even mythology
that is don Quixote is not based on a
classical myth or, or a traditional, uh,
story handed down orally.
Techie.
Hotter is a new story.
Uh, Indiana servant.
This boasts that it is new.
It is no small accomplishment to set out,
to write a narrative without precedents
to make of individual invention.
They're fundamental
factor of a literary work.
The divine comedy.
Tell us an original story.
Yet it is based on received
popular and cultural traditions,
the sense to hell,
a sense to heaven and it
calls and incorporates many
stories from biblical and
classical traditions that
they can run by Boccaccio.
Some of you may have read it retells
tales drawn from many popular and cultural
sources to their same goes for of course,
for the pastoral and the
chivalric romances about
which I will be speaking soon.
But the story of a man who
goes mad because he reads
too much has only one known
source and it is so trifling
as as to be dismissed.
Although the fact that it
exists is of some importance.
Uh,
the very act of invention on sort of
antithesis part is an important modern
component of the work invention is
the hallmark of modern literature.
Now, how could such a revolutionary
work up here in Spain?
I'm sorry to make this assumption,
but your conception of Spain cannot be,
but the result of the black legend.
What is the black legend?
The black legend is the bad
press that Spain's enemies,
uh, disseminated beginning
in the 16th century.
About the mistreatment of the Indians
out about Spain's backwardness and
brutality, uh, and, and, and,
and so forth. Uh, your images,
the inquisition,
religious intolerance as certain
primitiveness and backwardness.
This is all embedded in the
English language. You're going to,
you cannot escape it.
It is full of what we call factoids,
things that are almost true but not quite.
We call factoids derisively of course.
Yet during the 16th and 17th centuries,
Spain Produce Serantes Velasquez,
the character of don't Huang
the picaresque or figures,
uh, authors or kinds of writing that
are at the core of the modern western
tradition. How could
that be? So the key hot,
they aided by Elliot Imperial's pain,
which you are,
I hope dutifully reading will help
dispel these perceptions as well as my
comments in the course.
Now,
let me clarify as much as possible the
confusion about terms such as novel and
Romance,
that confusion that is augmented by the
fact that they don't quite coincide with
their cognates in Spanish.
Cognates are a words in two different
languages at sound, the same, uh,
but then sometimes, uh, are not
the same, uh, uh, in meaning.
So romance is a term derived
from the name Rome of course,
meaning that originally these were works
written in the languages derive from
Latin, that is French, Spanish, Italian,
Portuguese and so forth.
So those are the importance that those
begin with the Webster's definition for
romance.
It says originally along narrative
inverse or pros written in one of the
romantic dialects.
It says in Webster's,
remember what I said about
language and dialect.
The language is a dialect with an army,
meaning that,
uh,
people who speak a certain dialect become
powerful enough and imposed it on the
rest of the population.
So originally a written in one of the
romance dialects about the adventures of
nights and other to evaluate heroes to
a fictitious tail dealing not so much
with everyday life, us with extraordinary
adventures or mysterious events.
That's the western definition of romance.
A popular dictionary of literary
terms gives the following,
uh,
for Romance Romance,
a fictional story in verse or prose
that relates improbable adventures of
idealized characters in some remote or
enchanted setting or more generally a
tendency in fiction
opposed to that of realism.
Uncle.
Now etymologies are fun,
but they don't always clarify what a
word means in the present. And in fact,
sometimes words works.
Uh,
the tamales work against
such a clarification.
How many know, or how useful
is it to know that candidate?
The word candidate, for example,
derives from the Latin word,
can be reduced for Hawaii,
doesn't help you in the present to know
that at all helped you be pedantic if
you tell somebody or if you
bring it up in, uh, in that, uh,
in that party that I always mention
here at which a Yaley can be pedantic by
saying candid derives from Kunduz
in Latin, which means what?
Um,
or that is a very tough guys story
that you've told me in any case,
uh, in, in this case, knowing
that the term romance,
the rise from Rome and that, um, that it,
that it indicates that these stories
were written in the romance languages.
It does provide a historical insight.
Romances emerged after the breakup of the
Roman Empire during the Middle Ages as
the various national languages
are quiet individual identities.
So it,
so we have now a historical
period that the etymology,
romance gifts,
so in English romance beans,
a story with the linear plot and on
changing characters want to be sold to
follows another. And the heroes
and heroines remain the same.
This is the reason,
uh,
romances of chivalry are cold romances.
The romance form is
preferred by popular fiction.
And by works with an ideological
indoctrination purpose,
they are easy to follow
and their moral is clear.
Many cartoons, for instance, uh,
have the form of a romance cartoons,
comic books, novels. On the other hand,
our works in which there is a
clash between the characters,
the protagonist,
and the settings in which they move.
Remember the quotation from
Luke acts in my earlier lecture,
uh,
and in which the characters evolve as
the result of the actions in which they
are involved.
Characters and the romances don't change.
They're always heroic and so forth.
Characters in the novels do change,
uh, evolve, uh, uh,
because of, of the actual,
now,
Vicky is the first such a case of this
clash between the protagonists on his,
uh, uh, uh, setting. Uh, uh,
although an argument can be made in favor
of the picaresque on a work that I'll
be mentioning today. Again, I
mentioned it in the last class,
last Ellis Celestina already, uh, uh,
has that clash between protagonist and
setting and there's change and characters
evolve, but the Quixote is
the first, uh, it's the first,
uh, case. Uh, now I think,
and I hope now we have,
I hope a clear terminological
distinction between normal and romance.
And you will understand
when I speak about them.
Now get confused when
we know that in English,
picturesque stories are
often called romances.
This is particularly among
English department types. Um,
while in Spanish we call him,
we called them no [inaudible] novels.
I will always refer to picaresque
tales as novels because they are,
uh, they are according to the
definitions that have given up off. Now,
if you know Spanish,
you may be further confused by the fact
that girl Muncie in Spanish is a ballad
and narrative. Originally popular
porn, like the English balance.
Okay.
So you must keep these
distinctions clear in mind.
If you happen to read something in Spanish
and you hear and he read Romancing,
it is not a romance in the sense that
I've been explaining it is a pawn.
Yeah. What was it? That donkey haughty.
So avidly wanted to become,
let me clarify too.
What did you valid romances were,
because this is something that is
taken for granted everyone or devalued,
no less.
That does clarify.
I like to clarify things and
to start from the ground up.
What is it that don't be hot?
They want it to become,
what is this whole business
of the romances of chivalry?
First as I did with the term the romance,
then we clarified the background
of the word ci, Val, Rick,
she valid.
Rick comes from the French word Chevelle
or horse and it reflects the fact that
the knights form of
transportation was the horse.
What does French up to do with
English? Well, William the conqueror,
the battle of Hastings, the invasion of
England by the French and all of that,
which you learned in, uh, elementary
school or high school, uh,
on the fact that English to French
is one of the sources of, uh,
of modern English. So, uh,
but the horse was more than
just a form of transportation.
It was an instrument of warfare,
a prize possession with
each having a sonorous name,
if at all possible.
The horse work was part
of the knights identity,
hence the whole business about naming his
horse at the beginning of the Quixote.
Now you understand that part, uh,
of the, uh, uh, culture of horses.
Was it kind of courtesy? Uh, so, uh,
we have in English also, uh,
uh, chivalrous for instance,
horses have always spawned a whole
culture of their own and have Laura left a
large imprint on languages because
there were the, the, the, the,
the principal mode of transportation
to the part of the 20th century.
You can imagine. So, uh,
so technically a etymology clichy
Valerie [inaudible] is a horsey romance
or more appropriately
romances about horsemen.
Uh,
in Spanish,
the etymology is clearer as the romances
of chivalry are simply goal. Nobody,
Dick [inaudible] and [inaudible] is
the workforce for horse in Spanish now
evaluate the romances or in Spanish?
No,
as they go by and he asked where the
popular literature over the late Middle
Ages and early renaissance who's
dissemination was greatly aided by the
development of print.
I'm talking about the
14th and 15th centuries.
The printing presses or you
don't doubt? No doubt. No.
What's developed in the 15th century
making available to many readers books,
including the Bible,
which only a very few had access before
we had a copy of the Gutenberg Bible in
our own Beinecke library.
If you went to go look at it
now,
this development of the printing press
had a decisive impact on literature
because it increased, its
different, it's this dissemination,
so the Quixote and the knoll in general
owe their existence to this invention.
As we can see by the impact,
the romances of chivalry hat on our hero
and the large number of them that he
had in his library. If you've got really
chapter on the scrutiny of his love,
the library,
the romances of chivalry,
where the first best sellers,
they are entertaining.
And I encourage you to read one or
two if you have, uh, if you have time,
uh,
now that you valued romances originated
in France and do you ride from the
homeowner or courtly romance?
Coahoma Google in French [inaudible],
uh,
eventually became the name for novel,
but go home and Cook Twat or courtly
romance was the narrative inverse,
which was the favorite of feudal lords,
no longer engaged in military exploits
who looked back with nostalgia to a
heroic age.
The same as don Quixote will.
The Hemanchu Twan took it steams from
classical legends such as the Trojan wars
or the exploits of Alexander
the great even Oriental Tales,
but it preferred themes
derived from Britain legends,
legends from Brittany such as
that of Tristan and Isolde.
The nights in pursuit of the holy grail
grail like Parsifal and Maryland and
Lancet road or Arthurian
tales about Arthur,
the real or imaginary King of Britain
and the knights of the round table.
You have heard about all of these.
All of these adventures take
place in a fantastic atmosphere,
shrouded in a vague kind
of lyricists and poetry.
When these hormone trois,
remember embarrassed and so forth,
were turned into prose narratives.
The romance that you've all read
romances appeared each of these books.
How does a hero in knight errant
that incarnated heroism, Hammertoe,
fidelity, and what's the defender
of justice and of the oppressed?
The night was involved in the most
extraordinary adventures against fantastic
and frightening wrongdoers.
He's passionate love for an
idealized lady dominated.
He's thought love was a fundamental
component of these narratives.
The night would offer to his lady.
The glory of his fix.
This love for a lady is the same as
courtly love, which as you may know,
is buyer the medieval lyric.
Okay.
And, uh, what's a fashion, uh,
involving all sorts of rituals,
uh, in the courts of elegant ladies? Uh,
it's too long a story to be
told, but, uh, think that the,
the romances of jewelry are, uh, uh, uh,
a shot through as it were,
with the idea of, of,
of courtly love.
This,
we're not just a military heroes,
but they were also great lovers in Spain.
They were,
uh, two notable antecedents do the
romances of chivalry in the 15,
the in the 14th century
[inaudible] see far,
but these are should not concern,
concern during the 14th century,
all of the European books of
chivalry were disseminated in Spain,
uh, in, uh, adaptations and translations,
particularly those of
the blood tone or cycle.
The most significant chivalry romance
in terms of circulation and influence as
well as impact on the Kihatha was ama.
This the gala about which you will hear
and read a lot throughout this semester
because he is don't be
hopeless chief model.
Okay.
Which was first it was
written around 1492.
That'd be rocky year when
so many things happened. Uh,
but was published in 1508 in Saragossa.
It is known that there were stories about,
I'm Elisa Qa dating as far back as the
early 14th century and Montalvo who has
its author,
uh,
estates in the prologue that he took
the story written by several authors,
divided it into four
books and recasted it,
adding a few touches and a fifth book
about planned young and Melissa's son,
the chivalric romances
current did have many sequels,
much like today's soap
operas and television,
and responding to the same kind
of demand from the public. Uh,
this could end here. We want more,
more, I'm at least adventurous. We want,
I'm a decent sons at ventures and so
forth. Uh, in fact, all popular fiction,
uh, from, uh, Sherlock
Holmes to James bombed, uh,
is sequential in this fashion,
which is the reason why soap operas
are derisively called in Spanish Cooler
Varonis from lever I snake because it's
a snake that goes on and on and on.
And so this was the way that the
romances of chivalry, as you saw, uh,
if you have, if you read the chapter
on the scrutiny of the library,
the MIDC is a very free and application
of novels from the Britain Cycle.
It is a complex network of the most
varied and marvelous adventures.
Uh, it tells the story of
his, uh, of his birth, uh,
virtually in the river because he's thrown
in the river from which he is. I said,
baby, uh, to hide his mother's sin
because a, they were not married.
His parents are where a king
and a queen. And, uh, uh, he's,
he's rescued and trained
us. I say, uh, uh, uh,
as a night, uh, in, in
combat. Uh, then he,
he falls in love with Arianna.
Arianna becomes his beloved.
So I'm at least an Ariana is one
of the great couples of literary,
uh, history. He is put
through all kinds of,
of trials, uh, on the, he's
enchanted and disenchanted.
Uh,
and he is a most loyal and faithful
of lovers against all temptations from
various, uh, uh, uh,
a lady's, uh, in fact,
he, uh, is, uh, forced, uh,
to go, uh, through the
arch of faithful lovers,
uh, which could only be crossed by
lovers who had been absolutely faithful.
Uh,
so how many people can go through it,
uh, and, and so forth.
This is what is in Tokyo,
this imagination and
desires, this figure, uh,
of this invincible,
a hero who's noble on a great a lover.
Uh,
and, uh, this book was so
important in the 16th century,
uh, that it'd be good, acquire
it didactic value. I mean,
it was a, uh, use as a
model for department,
uh, and for courtesy
even more so. It's, it's,
we're past the model
for a courtly behavior,
uh,
which was written by a great it
Hallean writer called Baldassarre.
Castiglione. [inaudible]
is one of, uh, several,
uh, uh, important renaissance figures that
you're going to be hearing about here.
His last name is written like this.
Okay.
And his book is called the courtroom
and it was published in 15, 28.
Uh, it, it, it was a very
important book. Uh, but the Ama,
this was much more fun to
read and therefore in soar
past got Costa units book
as a source of, uh, models for department,
for people in the courts. Um, so
yeah,
it is for all these reasons,
it's not the Ama Lisa chief great success.
I'm on the greatest in Spanish literature
and many express their amelioration
for it in gray, including great
political, uh, an intellectual, uh,
figures.
It was for the readers of the time,
the only possibility for innovation,
the only food for their fantasy,
the romances of jewelry
were in the 16th century.
What movies and television
shows are for us today.
But the romances and Amaris in
particular had their detractors.
Spoilsports are everywhere all the time.
Who saw in such book a
threat to public morals.
Uh,
they became a topic of debate.
And this is behind the role.
I'm at this place in the Quixote.
And the reason why I said Avantis
says that he writing his book,
uh, against them to, uh, uh,
make fun of them in such a way that
people will not read them anymore.
He's entering the,
supposedly the debate about the value
or lack there off of the romances of,
of Ho, of jewelry. So No,
I hope you have a clearer idea of what
it was a donkey halted, wanted to become.
So it's not vague. What he wants
to please is clearer and concrete.
I suppose in modern day Don Quixote
would like to be James Bond,
um,
because we have to assume a modern Alonzo
Kiano to be middle aged and to have
grown up with, uh, uh, James
Bond as the, as the image of,
of, of heroism. I read that, that, uh,
Senator Kennedy in the last
hours of his life or days, uh,
would watch bond movies for entertainment.
Obviously for a man of his age,
a James Bond was the,
the, the, the, the we of
heroism and the devil, Nah.
Or good looking, all the women fall for
him and that sort of thing. So if you,
I guess maybe your parents or
your grandparents, not you,
if you want it to become like you hoped
they would, they would want to be a, uh,
a James Bond.
Now
I'm at least was the most obvious and
allowed by Serantes precursor of the
Quixote in Spanish, but what were, uh,
set Vantis his predecessors
among a more serious Spanish,
uh, literary work, which
were the, the Spanish works.
That's the rant. This
had red absorbed, uh,
incorporated into his
own literary, uh, uh, uh,
project.
I have mentioned some of these.
I want to mention them again because I
want to lay the groundwork in the most
thorough way possible
so that, you know, uh,
the first was last sale Stena,
which I mentioned in the last class.
Uh,
now it has several titles,
but I think I settled for less.
Ellis Tina,
which is from 1499 written by Fernando.
Hurdle hus
is of indeterminate jaw.
The closest description
would be a dramatic dialogue.
Last Ellis Tina is the most
significant precursor to survive this.
It is a tragic story of two lovers,
two young lovers Callisto in Maryvale
who comes to make their love under the
guidance of a go between the protagonist
Sally's Tina [inaudible] and all whore
madame of a whorehouse and which,
but in spite of these
unsavory characteristics,
she is the heroine of the
work. This is the most, uh,
original,
uh,
aspect of this work that the protagonist
is an old whore go between which and so
forth.
Still,
she is the heroine in the
sense that use willful and uh,
and uh, goes to, it goes against the fate.
And now there is a clear,
a clash between neoplatonic notions
of love, typical of the, uh,
of the renaissance and,
and the court integration and the sordid
and cynical view of humankind and of
love in particular,
Celestina controls the whole city
because she controls people's erotic,
uh, adventures. There are
two worlds, not have salad,
Stena the servants and horse and,
uh,
that of the lovers Calisto and many
ways parents, we tried the gentry.
So there is also a class clash here.
Calisto Jackie Haldane they're
making because he wants to play act.
The role of the courtly lover he's
killed when he falls off a wall.
The wall of cell garden where
he has been making love to her,
uh,
cell is the billionaire commit suicide
on Selestica is murdered by the servants
because she has swindled them to,
uh,
sell Latinos a pitiless book that,
with what can already be called
a, a realistic, uh, quality.
I'll talk about realism in a minute.
The second important work
is the other one that I mentioned,
but I want to now mention
more clearly lovey.
They last Saturday,
Nelson Lasa Bdo,
they totally miss.
This is the first picaresque novel,
no known author. Uh, it is, uh,
the life told to a judge as
in a deposition by a petty
criminal to justify his
current status. He at the end, from
the perspective that he writes,
is married to the arch mistress.
So he is a front,
he's a couple. The husband who is
compliant with societies, he park reeses,
uh, Lossa your tells his life from
birth to the present. What he writes.
This is a life, a scene from the
perspective of a low class individual,
a criminal who learned his tricks from
his first master who was ironically a
blind man. Guzman. They'll farace.
I won't give you the whole title,
but this is good enough because this
is how it is known is the second most
important picaresque novel
that I want to Minster.
Okay.
[inaudible] 15,
g nine to nine before Guzman got Russia,
uh,
is a four part Pawlik stale of a
criminal toll in the first person also
following the formula. But the
difference is that here, the life is,
is told after a religious
conversion to the good.
So the story of Guzman's life is laced
with sermons about where he went wrong
and ways to improve his morals.
But this retrospective moralizing is
always tempered by the appeal of the
stories about sin.
Sin Is more interesting always.
Guzman became the model picaresque
instead of anthesis time. Um,
there are clear allusion
steward in the hotel.
This is why you can see the genealogy
within the Spanish tradition.
Now what these words works,
a show is the emergence and
development of realism as we know it.
And we should be continued
in the work of Servantez,
particularly Vicky Haughty and a lead
all the way through to the 17th and 18th
century or 19th century
novels. I mean, here, this is
the beginning of realism. Uh,
its emergence in my view,
has a great deal to do with the Catholic
kings about whom you're reading.
And Elliot, the formation of
a new modern state with a,
with a large bureaucracy
and, and a very, uh,
large, also peanut, uh, uh,
not only peanut cultural but penal
institutions to punish this, uh,
uh, uh, this, this, this criminals, um,
a Spanish criminologist called Rafael
Sally just in the 19th century,
link's the picker risk with the
birth of the social sciences.
He thinks that in the picaresque
and in this kind of novel,
we have the beginnings of the
study of society as criminology,
sociology, and so forth, would
study it in later centuries.
But this is the origin.
Okay.
Here in this,
uh,
in this work that is a search
for truth about human nature. In,
so in the social commerce of people
at the lowest possible levels where
civilization as it were,
has barely reached.
Uh,
there is an emphasis on the material
and the sordid in this works against
neoplatonic conceptuals of,
of humankind that are more
typical of the renaissance,
the sordid,
the ugly,
the dirty becomes aesthetically valuable
and appealing in this realistic works
in the behavior of the characters,
uh,
their actions, uh, and also, uh,
their attitudes.
The point is that this sort of probe into
the social is an attempt to uncover a
truth about the human no longer available
in the ancient classical literature or
its imitators in the renaissance.
It goes against that kind
of version of the human.
Okay.
This is too complicated, but
it is, but we'll get to it.
As semester evolves, it is,
uh,
rejection parallel to that of the car
as he formulates his philosophy of the
self when he sort of erases,
received, uh, to tradition.
Uh, but, uh, I will leave that,
I'll put that in the back burner
and we will get to it eventually.
In realism,
common common objects.
You will see common objects in
the Quixote appear frequently.
This begins, we sell is
Tina and uh, but it's, it's,
but it's a world mostly of the picaresque
through which Don Quixote passes the
characters. Accessories, uh,
are what endowed description of
this world with an aura of reality.
What did what, what they have, uh,
Sanchez wine skin for instance,
uh,
and so forth.
Uh,
liberals look for such common
objects as you read Dicky Halter,
you will see there is a focus on them.
Okay.
This is a parallel to a
development in painting,
which began with the work of Leo
Battista Alberti known as Alberti.
I'll just do this in passing, but I will
allude to it more during the semester.
Okay.
You wrote
a treatise called the peak Tuta
in very simplistic terms for Albertie
nearly invented was the sense of
perspective.
That is that that objects up here,
uh, in different sizes with, uh,
depending on where they
are in reference to a pawn,
the fleet boom to the vanishing
point in English, it'll come to me.
And so you understand objects according
to Albert t a r to appear in painting,
not flat,
uh,
as they appeared in
medieval painting board
in relation to how they appear to the
observer and how they are arranged
according to perspective hands,
objects appear now in all
their fullness when all there,
the roundness in all
their weight and measure.
This is a form of realism
that begins in painting.
Deputy Tuta is from
1435, 15th century. Uh,
Albert teak,
a harder,
an enormous influence on the
history of painting part on,
on philosophy too. I mean this was a way
of conceiving the perception of objects.
Also subject to time because,
because perspective in space
involves also extensive of time.
If something is back here and
something is here, this is closer,
I can get to it faster than I get to that.
If you understand what I mean. So this,
this is a now this is if you,
if you have seen Velasquez paintings,
I'm sure some of you have, you will,
you will remember how those objects are,
are uh, uh, just common everyday
objects. Suddenly how, um,
a full miss now, this is what will
appear in these novels in the cortex.
And this is part of the development
of, uh, of, of, of realism.
Now,
uh,
you will see that the, yeah,
this is a cliche about Spanish,
uh, literature of the Golden Age,
16th, 17th century. What will prevail.
It's a between this realistic conception
of vision of the world and the
idealistic a conception, uh, uh, uh,
that comes through the
neoplatonic tradition.
And that is the Taro say
embodied in donkey hotel. Okay.
Hottest an ideas perspective. And
Sanctuary is the realistic perspective.
A sanctuary is close to the material,
to the world,
materials that he wants to
eat if he possibly can. Uh,
while Don Quixote doesn't eat meat,
doesn't need to eat,
he lives in a world of ideas, but of
course they influence each other. Uh,
as you will see, this is one
of the great, uh, uh, uh,
things about the [inaudible] that
this character's influence each other.
So we could say that that is overall
the overarching clash in this works of
Spanish literature.
But keep in mind above all the
what I've said about realistic,
because realism will be one of the
triumphs of serve anthesis work.
Now let us finally turn to the Quixote.
I assume,
and I hope that you have read at least
the first few chapters and that by the
next lecture you will have read the
first 10 chapters as well as the assigned
readings in the case book,
which will give you a background.
I said Lantus is life that I'm not
giving you here. Uh, as well as other,
uh, materials. And of course,
the first chapter in Elliot,
which I think is now the prologue,
the prologue,
this 16 or five priorities.
One of the most important and famous
texts in Spanish literature and products
are very important always for Savantas.
Why?
Because of his concern about
the relationship between
creator and his creation.
And he's concerned about the
nature of the self, his own self,
which is a very renaissance preoccupation,
said Advantis products are
very much like montañas essays.
Now I've mentioned Castiglioni. Uh, I've,
I've now I mentioned Montanian,
these are great renaissance figures that
in the context of which advantage road,
and you have to remember
the custom Yoni Montagnier.
Uh,
and it is here that on introduces
one of his favorite tropes,
one that runs through the
whole of the Quixote irony.
Uh,
this is a very ironic prologue.
we just conveyed through a very seductive
kind of self deprecation instead of
aunties.
Yeah.
Uh, [inaudible] begins,
I don't reader Jarvis,
miss translates this gentle reader in your
translation, but it's there. So Paolo,
like Tor, uh, I don't read her,
said vantage assumes a reader who
comes to his book for entertainment,
not instruction and who
reads for not for work.
This is a novelty and a kind of challenge
in a period when the function of
literature was very much an
issue discussed by secular
and religious moralists.
But we soon see that was advantage
means by entertainment does not preclude
consideration of very thorny ethical
issues that involve reading and literature
in general. Uh, this,
these issues emerge
immediately in the prologue.
It is typical of Cervantes and you can
expect to see it in the rest of the work,
uh, to deal lightly and
humorously with weighty issues.
This is one of his constituents.
He's able to deal with Larry grave
issues in a very light and humorous way.
That is his perspective.
It's part of is ironic perspective.
Now the prologue, oh look what comes
first. It's a kind of epilogue.
Uh, it was written, uh, obviously, uh,
after he finished the book. This is,
uh,
you cannot take for granted the sequential
order of things as you read them.
They are sequential in a conventional way.
It doesn't mean the product
that's the vantage. Sat down,
wrote the prologue and then wrote the
novel he wrote in Oval and then wrote the
prologue to ponder about
what he had just finished.
Now there is a, in, in
the, in in the prologue,
a tone of a prevailing theme of doubt,
which is again,
an echo of, uh, of Montana. Uh,
now pass.
This explains the self deprecating
statements about his own creation and
inventive powers.
You know,
that they are weak and that what
else could he produce? And so forth.
At the very first paragraph
where he belittles himself, uh,
it is very much like Montagnier because
when 10 years stance is very modern
Montagnier rights with the resignation
of knowing that he will never out to do
the classics. By the way, there is a,
there is a very instructive piece
of Montana in the latest New Yorker
in the latest New Yorker. I mean,
don't, 10 is still very relevant, uh,
on, uh, speaks to the modern, uh, mine.
Um, he writes with the
resignation of knowing that he
will never do the classics,
that he will never really know
the truth even about himself.
And that received knowledge is
of dubious value. For instance,
he and his famous essay
called uncanny balls,
he asks what business the
Europeans have an imposing.
Their religious doctors are natives of
the new world who had been getting along
just fine with their own beliefs.
And he says that it is worse school to
roast people alive as Europeans do to
torture them, done to roast them
once they're there and eat them. Um,
and uh, of course he's, he's
right about, about that. Uh,
he's a relativist in a post Copenhagen,
a world in which I'm still talking about
Montana in which we know that the earth
is not the center of universe pence,
human kindness at the center,
either in the way that it was
believed to be before in his prologue.
70 sounds very much like long
tenure. Who, if it was not a source,
it was clearly a kindred spirit.
They were both hamlet like in
their display of doubt. Of course,
Shakespeare had red mom Pena.
Now who is this friend who
suddenly appears in the prologue?
Of course it's a made
up friend, is a, is a,
is that an imaginary friend that's a
randos invents a on to turn the prologue
into a story, uh, and uh,
in which is going to discuss how to
route right a prolo while writing the
prologue. And that is the, the whole
joke behind this was a big joke.
Uh, so the, this was fun.
Both of telling stories rather than
expounding on doctrine and have dialogue.
He loved dialogue, uh, uh,
of having a topic discussed
from various points of view.
This will be throughout
the whole of the chaotic.
And we have it already in the prologue.
He has a dialogue with his imaginary
friend is having a dialogue with himself
and he's created this thing as
we do occasionally, you know,
create an imaginary friend or
someone with whom we speak on,
which is just a virtue and
another version of ourselves.
Yeah.
Different points of view.
A savant Savantas likes these things
that are being discussed from different
points of viewers. You
will see, uh, now the main,
the main topic of the prologue is the
genesis and intention of the book. Uh,
a common topic for a prologue only that
here it is told as the issue of how to
write a prologue is
discussed. Uh, there is, uh,
no, there is an apparent contradiction
here at the beginning said,
when says this book could be other than
my black myself because I'm his father.
Then he says,
no,
I'm the stepfather by which he means
that is merely merely the transcriber of
this book by see the unmetered billing.
Kelly is fictitious morrish author about
whom you will hear a lot in the book.
Uh,
this is the first of many disclaimers
of authorship in the Quixote.
Uh,
what Cervantes is probing here
is the genesis of literature,
the genealogy of invention,
which can no longer be taking it for
granted as following the rules of,
uh,
of renaissance poetics.
In what way does a book
belonged to its author?
This is why I said Vantis marks the usual
front matter of other books in which
authors boast of their area,
audition and others to attest to
the quality of the production. They,
the whole business that is talking about
all these sonnets that he could have
asked other people to write for
him and so forth. By the way,
those songs exist in the book and the
left out of the, uh, of the translation,
the front matter in a book is everything
from the title all the way to the
beginning of the book prologue,
preface, acknowledgement.
It's called the front matter loss,
preliminaries in Spanish.
If you want to learn that in
Spanish, uh, this, uh, this,
um, sonnets about the book in praise
of the book or like today's Blurbs,
you pick up a book and you find that
there are some blurbs. Roberto, Sally,
Julia says there is a praise
and what has happened is that,
uh, the, the, the person
blurbing the book, uh,
has been one of the readers will the
press to accept or another book and then
they ask you to,
uh,
to excerpt something from your
report and put her in the back.
All our times they just send
you the book and say, please,
would you write a blurb
blurb for this book?
Many people are in many people who
do it without reading the book. Oh,
one of the greatest, you know, and
they just write. So it's the same here.
This is what said,
this is marketing.
But what he does is instead of
going outside for legitimation,
he has literary characters,
right?
The sonnets in praise of his book.
It's as if I wrote a book and I,
and I had a,
a blurb from James Bond to,
to continue with our,
with our fictional character.
What is doing is showing
that literature is solved,
the legitimating,
he's not going outside of fiction and
excited of literature for legitimation,
but it's using this literary
characters to be those who,
uh, place. Uh, the book is another game,
another, uh, a joke that
he is playing on the river.
So what else does the,
what does the,
the friend tell him to do?
The friend tells him to make up his
own sonnets and also to make up a false
bibliography.
I said Guerra and put on the margins,
all of these sources that
he never, uh, consulted,
uh,
as if you created a false,
we don't have a fee for a paper that
you've written. Uh, he says, yeah, what?
This, this is a, this is a joke. It's very
amusing joke, but it's also very serious.
What the, what the friend is telling
Saran disease. Forget about tradition.
Forget about Aristotle. Aristotle
never wrote about romances of Jibo.
You're doing something new.
You can just make it all up.
This is what the prior August,
that kind of money festival for the kind
of book that they Quixote's the kind of
original new book that it is,
that it can break with tradition.
The brentech make it all up.
I hope you don't take this
seriously yourselves in your
own big geographies when
write your papers. But this is nick.
This is the advice that different gifts.
He says, Oh, I thought
that you were Weiss. No,
what you have to do is this and that is
now there are digs there and low pay.
The they guy,
remember I mentioned him in an earlier
class Lopei who was a very successful
playwright. He was rich, famous and vain.
And uh,
as a rant,
this is taking a dig at him because
apparently Lopei got himself some the
sorrows compendia of quotations,
familiar quotations and use
them in his works to make, uh,
to make it seem like he was very
erudite and learn it and not,
I also added the Gay Lopez.
They,
they got to his last name to make it seem
as if we were an aristocrat. You know,
the D in Spanish, in French,
Spanish or German, Vaughn, uh,
indicates, uh, aristocracy. So he's
taking a dig at Lopez and data in terror.
Lobeck lobby was just saw successful,
successful and lobby had also said
a few disparate and thing about.
But all of that is to sort of contingent
important thing in the prologue.
Is that the same way with tradition?
I'm beginning here a new,
I can make it up.
That is the whole point of the,
uh, now, uh,
I am going to end by simply alluding
to the beginning of the book.
The birth of Don Quixote is an act
of self invention by a man of 50.
At the age 50 was a very advanced age.
Age expectancy didn't go beyond late
thirties, early forties, at the time.
So,
uh,
this is also conventional with Savannah
is his own age. He's in his late fifties.
When he publishes his book. He
says that in the prologue, uh,
it says lack of self invention.
My amount of 15,
he feels free to create
himself beyond family.
We don't know anything. We don't learn
anything about Don Quixote is family.
Only about his niece.
But we learn anything about his,
his parents know about his birth,
know about his needs.
No.
Uh,
Cervan Cervantes has created
a hero who is beyond Freud,
uh, beyond Freud's family romance.
You know, and Freud's theories,
the family romance is
Mommy, Daddy, and the child.
The boy is in love with Miami and all
of that. That is the family romance.
And you go through life with a resentment
of daddy or your love or secret love
for money and all of that. That's
the family romance. This is,
this is a mock version of Freud,
but Cervantes says character is
born beyond Freud. When you're 50,
who cares about your parents and
all of that. You are who you are.
And not only is he who hears,
but he wills himself to be
something else at the age of 50.
It is important that donkey,
how to be that old is,
can you think of another literary
hero who is that old cell?
Stina but she was,
she had a US co protagonist,
the two young lovers,
but now protagonists were either
men in their full strength,
like Ulysses. An Ia is, uh, the
pilgrim in the divine comedy.
I think it's three, three,
uh, the, not an old land.
Uh,
why?
Because it's his self invention is an
act of will based on nothing isn't beyond
all of the pressures
of family and of need.
And this is why he can invent himself.
Uh,
Doki holders,
drew family and genealogy
is the books that he read.